[Musique]
pendant une semaine un centre de
vaccination éphémère a pris place à
l'orangerie du château de versailles
mille injections par jour était prévu
avec du vaccin kaiser bio ntech le but
ne perdre aucune dose le matériel et le
personnel volontaires ont été mis à
disposition par le département
six élèves du lycée louis-blériot de
trappes ont participé à une
visioconférence avec irène tôt leur et
députée européenne française un échange
intégralement en anglais partager avec
des classes chypriote néerlandaise et
slovaque
la femme politique a partagé son
expérience dans le biais de questions
réponses en rendez vous qui s'inscrit
dans le cadre du programme erasmus
le ministre de l'intérieur gérald
darmanin annoncé un report de quatre
policiers supplémentaires dans la
circonscription de police de plaisir fin
avril les élus s'étaient réunis devant
le commissariat d'arrondissement pour
une conférence de presse il déploré à
l'époque de ne pas faire partie des
effectifs supplémentaires annoncées par
le président de la république
le groupe hachette livre devrait
déplacer son site saint quentinois à
l'horizon 2026 pour alain ville afin de
se moderniser et de s'agrandir
actuellement installé sur une zone
d'activité à maurepas et coignières 650
salariés intérim il travaille
un coup dur pour les maires des deux
communes il se questionne sur l'avenir
du site
[Musique]